hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
the winter depression is finally over
video game releases begin to ramp up
from this month onwards here's eight
games looking to pry away your
hard-earned cash over March 2020 as an
FYI here if you are looking forward to
Final Fantasy 7 remake just like me then
you should know that that's being put
back to April other than that let's
crack on probably the biggest game of
the month is the return of doom
this time it's doom eternal a direct
follow-up to the 2016 doom with
everything taken to the next level doom
eternal is instantly a balls-to-the-wall
intense shooter which feels great to
play according to every single preview
I've seen so far the core elements are
the smooth gunplay the insane takedowns
the heavy metal soundtrack perfectly in
sync with the actions on screen which
somehow amps up our adrenaline before
important faceoffs with hell's minions
here's the best mechanic in the game
after damaging an enemy they begin to
flash allowing us to perform a gruesome
takedown here's the important part by
completing that move called the glory
kill it awards us some health
regeneration it's cool isn't it well if
you need ammo simply whip out your
chainsaw and continue the bloodbath
instant ammo and finally should you
require armor simply set demons on fire
no more searching for health are waiting
to recover attacking is the best form of
Defense when you're a Doom Slayer
there's a few other mechanics to note
such as new open-world elements to
discover and get this RPG elements in do
upgrade weapons and mod them out as you
see fit and if the gunfights become
stale simply keep playing and the game
throws new abilities at you constantly I
could honestly talk about doom eternal
all day if it sounds like your kind of
thing March 20th is the day you can jump
back into hell on ps4 PC and Xbox
[Music]
next we have the PlayStation exclusive
neo - if you're a Souls born lover you
likely already know about neo - neo is
exactly that though it's a tough
action-adventure role-playing game
designed to challenge your skill and
timing for the entire duration of the
games length by the way if you have PS
plus the first game was given out last
month if you remember to add it to your
account you can get to grips with a
difficulty level right now in terms of
story neo - is a predecessor to the
original game and sets us on the path to
obtain the spirit stones in 1555 feudal
Japan yeah we are samurai a war-torn
country in which everyone is afraid of
the spiritual beings known as yokai and
you've guessed it you play as a renowned
yokai hunter neo - we'll have you
learning new styles and attack patterns
for a host of different weapons so dare
you venture forward March 13 if you're a
glutton for punishment the persona
series is huge with every iteration a
new audience discovers the game and
wonders how they lived without it for so
long the basic premise is a single year
in a Tokyo high school following the
experiences of a character with a
codename Joker the year is filled with
both scripted events and completely
random encounters what's interesting in
this RPG is the additional content in
the Royal version see it as as a game of
the year version or a complete edition
as new character interactions are both
added openly and hidden away within the
game for you to find this means even
game veterans that finish this one two
years ago will find this a new
experience and that's what we told -
there is so much new content here it
will feel like a new game - all there
are multiple endings to uncover some of
which are depressing to say the least
but with additional endings comes the
magic of the word I love replayability
after researching this series I am going
to take the plunge wish me luck Besson
the five oil releases on ps4 on March
3rd
another gang which drops on March 3rd is
the division twos major expansion
warlords of New York one year ago the
division two released and moved the
looter cover shooter to Washington DC
well as the name suggests we're going
back to New York and continuing the
story from the original game here's a
quick recap a smallpox pandemic wiped
out almost all of New York leading to
the division agents becoming active one
of the first agents to be called in air
and Keena changed his mind of
mid-mission and saw the virus as a way
to take control for himself and his
ideals we the players were then given
the call to hunt him down fast-forward
six months and the world is not looking
in a great place but we're back where it
all started the level cap is now raised
at 40 and a new line of endgame
activities has been added known as
seasons and of course as always we can
choose to team up or play alone the base
division 2 game is crazy cheap at the
moment so this may be more appealing
than you first thought hitting stores on
March the 3rd on ps4 PC and Xbox one
[Music]
next is a good old annual spot title MLB
the show 2020 Major League Baseball it's
a huge spot in the US right well apart
from well Japan the rest of the world
doesn't really play rounders and
baseball after infancy so please forgive
me for my lack of understanding in his
next sentence as a fully licensed game
all your favorite stick swingers and
ball throwers are here conflict with
huge glove because catching needs
assistance in this spot for some reason
I wonder how many people I've offended
they're my but I told you I'm completely
clueless this will be the last time MLB
the show appears solely on PlayStation
as Xbox and switch will be getting their
own versions going forward if you like
baseball video games good for you enjoy
this one March the 17th if you're
interested hey Nintendo switch family
another Animal Crossing game drops this
month this is new horizon as always
these are life simulation games
conducted in real time which forces you
to come back regularly to check up on
your inhabitants starting on a deserted
island your task is to build up a
civilization from the ground up March
20th and it's all yours on the Xbox side
of things
have you seen bleeding edge it's a 4 on
14 fighter from Ninja Theory set in
third-person with inspiration from
overwatch fortnight and Team Fortress
bleeding-edge is a take on team fighting
it's all about synergy to win battles
going in solo pretty much leads to death
every time so this is about team
integration I gotta admit it looks like
a free game it plays like a free game
but it's not free it's cheap though so
maybe check it out
March 24th if you're interested Xbox and
PC
[Music]
and finally back in 1998 valve released
the game which impacted many people's
childhoods half-life then in 2007 the
series ended on a cliffhanger and for 13
years we've waited for the next episode
well this month half-life Alex releases
but not on console and not really on PC
as Heath expects anyway half-life alex
is a VR title following the events of
half-life 2 we take control of Alex as
she attempts to fight off the combine
and here's the hook we have gravity
gloves it's said to act like
anti-gravity weapons you've seen in
other games or abilities like control
from last year with the game of the year
for many people it's an awesome mechanic
which doesn't get old the real questions
are with half-life alex is simple are
you prepared to buy VR to play this one
game tough choice for many people March
23rd on Steam if that's your jam so
there we have it
eight new games March 2020 if nothing
floats your boat I totally think you
should save your cash for April it's a
huge month and the rest of the air is
packed too and the PS 5 and the new Xbox
are coming later in the year so Wow
video games I'm Adam from PlayStation
granade if you stayed this long can you
write Wii Sports for life in the
comments thank you very much see you bye
[Music]